i joke around about this
but i've been wondering who's going to
get to outer space first
the fast and furious franchise or tom
cruise
[Laughter]
what will it take for the fast franchise
to get to outer space
is it in fast nine or could it be in
past 10
you know i i think through the years you
know it's part of the fun
is is to come up with crazy ideas to
challenge ourselves
you know um but i i have to say i think
you know
we never do it just for the sake of
shock value
or just to you know just it always takes
something from the theme or the
character journey and i could say that
you know when i was working on fast nine
there was a thread uh that felt very
appropriate
to to take us to places we've never gone
to
and uh i drove to vin's house and i sat
down with them and we looked at each
other and we're like okay
this is the one this is the one that
we're going to try and it felt very
appropriate and so
you know i kind of can't wait to kind of
share with the world because you know
the more we kind of push and and and do
crazier
you know stunts and set pieces i think
the more
we have to check ourselves to make sure
we earn that